en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre tres
problemas que de manera conjunta se les
conoce con el nombre de teoremas de
existencia el primero del que vamos a
hablar es del teorema del valor
intermedio y lo que tienen en común
todos estos teoremas de existencia es
que dicen vamos a buscar algo en el
intervalo es decir existe un valor x en
el intervalo entre a y b donde algo
interesante pasa en el teorema del valor
intermedio vamos a suponer que si hay
continuidad en el intervalo cerrado de a
b y de hecho en todos estos problemas de
existencia vamos a suponer que la
función es continua en el intervalo
cerrado a coma b entonces la función
toma todos los valores
/ efe de am y fm
otra forma de pensarlo es tomar un valor
/ efe de am y fm incluyendo claro
efe de am y fm
llamemos ese valor el entonces lo que
nos dice el teorema del valor intermedio
es que si suponemos que la función es
continua sobre ese intervalo entonces
debe existir un valor entre a y b que
tome el valor de l y te desafío intenta
dibujar una función continua que vaya
del punto y coma efe de am al punto b
coma efe de tal que no pase por este
valor l y es que si es continua
tendrás forzosamente que pasar por el
valor de l la única forma de no pasar
por el valor de l es si tenemos una
función discontinua si éstas continúan
allí entonces podrías evitar el valor de
l pero como estamos suponiendo que es
continua en el intervalo entonces
pasarás por el entonces aquí es muy
intuitivo que si es continua entonces
existe un valor c entre a y b incluyendo
a o a ver tal que puedes tomar cualquier
valor que quieras
/ efe de am y fm así que este es el
primer problema de existencia
bien el segundo es el teorema del valor
extremo y este también creo es muy
intuitivo una vez más suponemos que la
función es continua en el intervalo
cerrado
pero aquí decimos mira si la función es
continua sobre este intervalo entonces
existen y por eso se llaman teoremas de
existencia
entonces existe un valor entre a y b y
puede pasar en a o en ven en donde la
función toma un valor máximo y existe
otro valor entre ibm donde la función
tomará un valor mínimo así que una vez
más trata de dibujar una función en
donde no tomes un valor mínimo y un
valor máximo sobre este intervalo si
dibujó una línea recta por aquí entonces
el valor máximo ocurre cuando x toma el
valor de bem y el valor mínimo ocurren
cuando x toma el valor de amd y si
dibujo algo como esto entonces observa
que el valor máximo una vez más ocurre
en este intervalo aquí en el valor de
sem y en este caso el valor mínimo está
ocurriendo bueno en x igual a
y dibujo algo no sé cómo esto entonces
en este caso el valor mínimo está
ocurriendo para este cierto valor de x y
el valor máximo está ocurriendo para
este otro valor de x lo único que nos
dice este teorema es que existen estos
valores en el intervalo cerrado y una
vez más la única forma en la que puedo
construir una función donde estos
extremos de la función a no existan es
en el caso en el que entregamos una
función que no sea continua por ejemplo
qué pasaría si dibujo una gráfica como
ésta donde tengo una función discontinua
bueno aquí claramente no tengo un valor
máximo de una manera similar podría ser
algo así donde no tengo un valor mínimo
pero tampoco tengo una función continua
una vez más si suponemos que la función
es continua entonces existen estos
valores extremos de mi función y de
hecho tenemos en caná khadem en algunos
vídeos donde profundizamos más esta idea
y bueno el último del teorema de
existencias será este el teorema del
valor medio
también es bastante intuitivo habla un
poco sobre la diferencia habilidad en la
derivada y ojo además de pedirle a la
función que sea continua en ese
intervalo también le pide ser
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto a
coma b
ojo si es diferenciable en este
intervalo entonces significa que la
gráfica es continua pero si es continua
en este intervalo no necesariamente es
diferenciable y entonces el teorema dice
si tengo una función continua y
diferenciable en este intervalo
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto y
continua en el intervalo cerrado ok
déjame dibujar eso bien entonces se
calculó la tasa de cambio promedio entre
los puntos
am y b efe db así que la tasa promedio
la voy a pintar de color rosa ok es la
pendiente de esta recta de rosa esta es
la tasa de cambio promedio bien lo que
me dice el teorema de valor medio es que
existe al menos un valor sem en donde la
derivada de la función en ese punto es
decir la pendiente de la recta tangente
en ese punto es igual a la tasa de
cambio promedio y de hecho podemos verlo
a simple vista para esta curva existen
varios puntos donde esto ocurre donde la
derivada se ve igual a la tasa de cambio
promedio
aquí la pendiente de la recta tangente
tiene la misma pendiente que la tasa de
cambio promedio del intervalo así que
esa sería nuestra ser y existe recuerda
que debe de existir es justo lo que
buscamos y de hecho puede ser más de un
valor por acá arriba por ejemplo me
parece que la pendiente de la recta
tangente es la misma que la tasa
promedio de cambio y por lo tanto
también sería no está sé que buscamos
así que cómo podemos construir algo que
no sea cierto bueno si suponemos que la
función no es diferenciable en ese
intervalo podríamos encontrar una
función donde no fuera cierto este
teorema es decir que no podríamos
encontrar un punto en donde la pendiente
de la recta tangente fuera la misma que
la tasa de cambio promedio así que por
ejemplo podemos ver este caso piensa en
la función valor absoluto aquí tenemos
algún tipo de función valor absoluto
donde tenemos una recta hacia este punto
y otra hacia este punto pero con
pendiente positiva ok ahora observa que
esta función no es diferenciable en esta
esquina
es decir no podemos encontrar la
derivada en ese punto y ahora no podemos
encontrar ningún punto en este intervalo
donde la pendiente de la recta tangente
sea la misma que la tasa de cambio
promedio y bueno tal vez podrías
argumentar que en este punto me pasa lo
que buscamos pero espera en este punto
no está bien definida la pendiente de la
recta tangente de hecho no está bien
definida una recta tangente ni bien
definida la pendiente entonces no
funciona y bueno en otros vídeos vamos a
profundizar más en este tema por ahora
puedo decir que es bastante agradable
ver los tres teoremas juntos estos
además hablan de la existencia de un
valor x en un cierto intervalo en donde
algo interesante pasa ya sea que tome un
cierto valor
/ efe de am y fm o que tome un valor
extremo de la función o donde la
derivada en ese punto es la misma que la
tasa de cambio promedio del intervalo
hasta la próxima